foreign
[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Friday January 13th I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
5G for years it's been billed as the key
to faster cell phone connections not
only that it was supposed to usher in a
world of connected possibilities for
technology 5G powered cars that notify
traffic lights when you're close 5G
powered robots performing surgeries or
preparing food but if you're feeling
like 5G Tech is it living up to all
those promises you're not alone
we've got our senior personal Tech
columnist Joanna stern here to explain
why and what you can do about it hey
Joanna Hey Zoe So Joanna maybe we should
start with some background why did we
expect 5G to be such a game changer
because the carriers made us think that
it was going to be the next coming of
Technology
Gods well carriers do this every time
they have a big Network upgrade but 5G
was particularly
just blown out right you had Verizon
with major ads you still see them
everywhere the 5G America is waiting for
T-Mobile had this crazy Super Bowl ad
with Miley Cyrus and Dolly Parton 5G
phones
then you had a t where they were saying
it's going to transform the future and
so there was just tons of marketing hype
about 5G and many people also remember
the race to 5G that we have to beat
other countries to 5G and it wasn't
really clear what 5G was going to do for
us as consumers but then we started
getting 5G phones and so they put the
focus there right you buy these 5G
phones you're gonna get blazing fast
speeds okay but a lot of us have 5G now
on our phones and it doesn't feel like
it's living up to its promises so why is
that well it depends on what network or
Carrier you have but the real reason is
is that 5G is not really meant for
phones 4G unlocked a ton of things that
we now do on our phones and made it
really seamless streaming Netflix Uber
because location services got better and
the data connection was faster Tick Tock
Instagram all these things loaded faster
on 4G and the mobile apps they were
built for these types of networks to
give better performance with lower
bandwidth and so now 5G comes along and
it's like trying to put out a t candle
with a huge fire hose you don't need
that much power on your phones so can
you explain a little bit you know what
do we need to know about how 5G works
just to make it a little bit clearer for
what we're getting on our phones and
maybe what we don't need the biggest
confusion about 5G has really been that
all 5G is created equal and so what
happened in the beginning of 5G really
is that really a lot of 4G became 5G and
so when your indicator on your phone
says 5G and you're expecting Crazy Fast
speeds well you might just be getting
something very similar to 4G in fact I
have Verizon I often just see the
regular 5G logo when I turn off 5G and
I'm back on LTE I really don't even see
the speed difference and don't feel that
difference so that was something called
Low band 5G then the real promise is
something called mid-band 5G and this is
sort of The Sweet Spot between the low
and the high obviously but it's The
Sweet Spot because it covers more space
and it has faster speeds than 4G
the issue is is that not all the
networks all the carriers had access to
this band of 5G T-Mobile has a lot of
this band because of their acquisition
of Sprint a few years back and so if
you're a T-Mobile customer you actually
really may see the benefit of 5G and
then there's this high band 5G which is
called millimeter wave it's less
frequent it's super fast but you've
pretty much got to be near a tower or in
one of these public spots where
millimeter wave 5G is available like a
airport or an arena so for people who
maybe made the switch to 5G and who are
possibly you know paying more to have it
what can they do to to get the most out
of it so number one thing is to just
look at your carrier right because even
if you have a 5G phone you may not be
actually getting the best 5G service and
so contact your carrier or look at the
plans my editor I'll call them out here
he thought oh I have five Gene he said I
don't see the 5G Ultra wide band
indicator you've been talking about
which is what what Verizon Brands it's
mid-band or high band 5G but he wasn't
paying for the plan that had the faster
network access then he started paying
for the plan and he started to see the
5G UW so the carriers will actually tell
you in the network indicator if you have
the mid band or high band connection on
T-Mobile it will say 5G UC on Verizon it
will say 5G UW and on at T it will say
5G Plus
because things were not complicated
enough
have the carriers said anything about
this I mean are we hearing from them at
all about what people should expect or
why 5G isn't as blazing fast as we maybe
thought it might be yeah so at T and
Verizon both are working on that build
out of that mid-band Network which
should make things better but they
ultimately also will point to the fact
that 5G has made some big difference in
some different areas one area is home
internet you can get a 5G router if
you're on Verizon or T-Mobile and that
means you can get these really fast
speeds at home when maybe you had an
older type of connection at home maybe a
cable and also you also can now deal
with the carriers versus using some
older cable company so that's one place
it has made a difference another place
that they'll point to and analysts
pointed to when I spoke to them was
during these points of heavy congestion
on the network say you're on a train and
everyone's on their phone say you're in
an arena and everybody's on their phone
5G gives you a higher data capacity so
so that may lessen the burden on you and
you may notice that things upload faster
or download faster I
in 5G isn't really for phones but when
do we expect that 5G might live up to
the connectivity promises that so many
people talked about
so the thing that the carriers and the
analysts told me is that a lot of the
promise of 5G comes with latency lower
latency latency is the time it takes for
data to travel from one point to another
right so the faster that connection the
more things can happen instantaneously
and that can help a lot with new
categories so drones self-driving cars
things that are not your phone
specifically we've been hearing about in
5G you know these robot surgeons you'll
have a surgeon in Miami who could
perform the surgery using all types of
computers and Technology where the robot
is let's say you're in New York right
and so you want that robot to be on 5G
or to have that low latency because you
wouldn't want it to take longer you
wouldn't want something to be not
instantaneous during surgery so all of
these things really depend on that
latency getting better which is going to
get better as these networks get better
so something to uh to wait for and
anticipate that's our senior personal
technology columnist Joanna Stern thanks
for joining us Joanna thank you
and that's it for Tech news briefing
this week our producer is Julie Chang
our supervising producer is Melanie Roy
our executive producer is Chris sinsley
and I'm your host Zoe Thomas a quick
heads up we'll be off on Monday in honor
of MLK day but we'll be back on Tuesday
with more Tech news thanks for listening
and have a great weekend
[Music]
thank you